we've got some breaking news for you
here at sky new centre and the british
medical council has called for a delay
in the easing of lockdown restrictions
in england scheduled of course for
monday
that's the 21st of june we're expecting
to hear from the prime minister about
that
on monday the bma says this fourth stage
of the roadmap
should not go ahead until there is a
better understanding of the implications
of the rapidly rising number of cases
the chair
of the bma council dr john nardpal said
case numbers are now rising rapidly and
we know that those
who are unvaccinated or have only had
one dose of the vaccine
remain vulnerable to getting the virus
the best protection
is only achieved at about two weeks
after the second dose particularly with
the delta variant
and we will not have enough of the
population properly
protected by the 21st of june
well we are as i said of course
expecting boris johnson to announce
whether the easing of restrictions will
take place on
the 21st on monday of course earlier on
the program we also heard about the
r-rate jumping didn't we between
1.2 and 1.4 and we know that this
indian variant is 64 more transmissible
within the household than the kent
variant so clearly
that's having an impact and the british
medical
association now saying that they think
the lockdown easing
and restrictions should be delayed that
will of course have a
more significant impact to businesses
which are hoping
to reduce that social distancing rule
and of course mask wearing
in pubs and restaurants for example